hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer and today
we are going to be talking about reasons
not to go to a coding bootcamp in 2021
now if you've seen any of my past videos
you know that i became a software
engineer this last
fall be after going through a coding
bootcamp myself
however having gone through this and you
know having a lot of knowledge of coding
bootcamps now
in general but also going through a
coding bootcamp during a parallelogram
like i
know certain things that these coding
bootcamps might not be telling you
and the goal of this video isn't to
deter anybody
i am just trying to provide information
and insights and provide you all with a
bigger picture
of things that you may not be getting
just so you can be more confident
in your decisions in a few days i'll be
posting a video as to why you
should go to a coding bootcamp in 2021
because again we're trying to get the
whole
picture or you know more parts of the
so make sure you subscribe so that you
can make sure you get that
as soon as it comes out so let's get
into it
the first reason you should not go to a
coding bootcamp in 2021
is because it's quite obvious it is
virtual y'all and coding bootcamp
is expensive which i'm not trying to get
into the next point here but
if you are paying money for something
that was once
in a different compa capacity and now
it's in this whole new sphere whole new
realm with all these whole new rules
and from the looks of it i mean correct
me if i'm wrong but
coding boot camps haven't changed their
prices and so now you're paying for
a less i'm just gonna be honest
for a less real experience but still
paying full price
but how like how is that fair
to be completely honest and so that's
something to really think about is it
worth getting into tens of thousands of
debt and when i
when i say tens of thousands i mean tens
of
thousands of dollars in debt for
something that you couldn't even get the
full experience of
when i went through coding boot camp it
was virtual
and for me to be honest
i am a person who prefers
to not wear pants
for meetings and you know not have
brushed my hair for x and x
class and things like that and so
this worked out very well for me oh
but there are so many people that this
doesn't work out for especially
when home includes your wife your
husband your children your mom and your
grandma like it
gets so hectic and so much more
difficult to concentrate
on this career shift of yours when
there's screaming kids in the background
and you know you have people to be
accountable for just a few feet away
from you instead of being able to
actually pack a bag
and go to a campus or a school
and get your work done for eight hours
and then come back
it's a lot harder for some people to
you know do that and i'll be honest i'm
a 22 year old
you know woman who does not have a
husband a wife
children people to be accountable for if
you saw my apartment it was just me
it was just me in this box it is that's
it so again
i'm i am in a whole such a different
situation
than many people are and so it's
something to think about when
choosing to pay eighteen thousand
fifteen thousand twenty thousand dollars
of something that you're not getting the
full experience
of the second reason to not go to a
coding boot camp in 2021 i hit on this
earlier
y'all it is expensive and if you were
like me
you lost your job you lost a lot of
maybe your savings trying to pay
your lease trying to pay your loans
trying to pay
this that and the other thing because
you
did not have a job anymore so now you're
dipping into
savings and you know maybe even taking
out loans or all of this
to just stay afloat and now you expect
me to get
on 20 000 debt on top of it no like
how how so that is something you
really need to consider and of course
you're considering it so
you know but for the sake of this video
and for the sake of full
transparency it's something to be very
very wary of because
if you lost your job that is
a very hard thing to put you and if
again if you're accountable to people
you and your family through now if you
do
have a family who would be able to pick
up the weight
and you know pick up the load for the
four six eight months that you would be
going to this boot camp
that's fantastic and that's you know
maybe reason to consider it
um more heavily um
and maybe you can get through this boot
camp
but it's still a lot to ask even of your
partner even of your mama it's still
a lot to ask so just
keep that very much in mind which you
know
money y'all i know you all keeping in
mind because it's money
the third reason to not go to a coding
bootcamp is because
let's say you do get that job you went
through coding boot camp for four
five six eight months and you do get a
job
that's one amazing and very much reason
to celebrate but because
of the economy right now
there is the possibility of your pay
being lower than if you had gotten the
job
out of a panoramic because
the company has limited funds now and
they have to
you know think about x y and z and they
have to you know
budget a lot more tightly than they
would have if all was good in the world
and so are you willing to go again into
this debt or
go through all of these stressors for a
job that you won't
even be paid as much as you
would have if this was a different time
and on top of that if you're getting
paid less
because of this parallelogram the person
next to you your co-worker or you know
susie down the hall
there's a good chance she's getting paid
more than you so are you also okay with
being maybe the person who's paid
the least in the office that's something
again
to think about if it's worth it or not
so the next thing to consider
let's say you went through the boot camp
your interviews
are virtual now they are through
zoom through microsoft through higher
view
all that are you conf
are you a person who gets very deterred
by
not having that one-on-one interaction
that human interaction
or is this your zone is this where you
can actually fly because you're actually
an introvert and so having a screen in
between
you and them is something that can
actually make you more comfortable
if it's the former that's
something to consider maybe it won't be
the
deciding factor of if you go to a boot
camp or not
but that's something that during your
boot camp you're going to need to
practice and really really practice
because
you could be an amazing person but if
that doesn't
communicate through a screen then
they're going to hire the person where
it does
communicate because at the end of the
day they want to be with people they
like i mean would you want to be in an
office for eight hours with
you know non-stop talking nancy like
no like you want to be with people you
like who fit
the culture who are about the mission
statement and everything
so if you can't show that because
there's a computer
and you are in your kitchen with no
pants on and all this
then that is something to very much
think about and practice please practice
that's just to that's just a skill and
all skills can be built upon and so
i'd highly recommend practicing just
even do what i'm doing right
now talk to this camera right over here
talk to a camera just talk to your phone
talk to your laptop and just
make it feel real and by doing that
hopefully when it is time for you know
the lights to come on
and you to really shine in front of that
interviewer for microsoft or twitter for
google
you are able to do that because now
there's actually a person on the screen
rather than a dark screen
you were talking to for 20 minutes like
i am the last reason to not go to a
coding bootcamp in 2021 is specifically
for people who are married or
are in a committed relationship this
panoramic has really really
tested the bounds of commitment
and being in a relationship and you know
compatibility and
all of that it has really stressed
relationships because let's say you
aren't able to see them as often because
now you're not able to
you know go on dates or you're not able
to do x y and z
now you there's the stressor of
household
expenses because
someone lost their job maybe both of
y'all lost your job and
it's it's becoming so strenuous to just
keep the roof on your head
you have that eviction notice you know
sitting right outside they can't defect
you
you know i'm pretty sure right now but
it's still not good to see on your
fridge you know on you know your door
so going to recording boot camp already
is such a big stressor i you know was
just
by myself and you know no real true
stressors and still
i wanted to just cry
cry cry cry more often than i care to
admit
because it's just so hard y'all it is
just so hard and i'll be linking a video
as to
really how to get through coding boot
camp
and really get through it as with as
much ease as possible
but even with these tips it's still hard
maybe not as hard as it would have been
without the tips but it's still
hard and so are you willing to add this
other difficult thing to your
relationship and just constantly just be
weighing it down because you have to
think about
if you all can survive it
as a as a unit if you can't that's
like amazing and that's what i pray for
that's why i pray for myself
you know like that's the goal but
i just it matters
what your support system looks like and
what your household situation
looks like because you really can't deal
with
so much stress on top of boot camp
itself because that will impact
your success within the boot camp and
will also
affect whether or not you get a job or
get a job
quickly post boot camp because if you're
so busy with this over here you're not
paying attention
to here so that is another reason to not
go to a cloning boot camp
in 2021 and maybe wait until
all is up and running in the world again
like i said before
i'm going to be posting a reasons to go
to a coding bootcamp in 2021 video
in just a few days so don't forget to
subscribe
but thank you so much for watching this
and
i it's it's very hard for me to make
this video because i
want you all to if you want
this life for yourself to become a
software engineer to make the switch
i want you to make the switch and so
it's very hard for me to say
these things but that's just the reality
of where we're at
and i definitely am a person who likes
knowing all the information so that i
can make the proper decision for
myself and so i hope i did that all for
you today so thank you so much and i'll
see
you later bye